à Laval le transport en commun et l'un
des plus modernes au Canada pour acheter
un ticket plus besoin d'aller à un
comptoir les clients peuvent dorénavant
taper leur carte de débit et crédit
physique ou virtuelle sur un terminal
pour monter à bord avec cette
transaction les usagers obtiennent un
passage et une correspondance de deux
heures plus c'est facile de pas en
transport en commun plus on espère que
nos citoyens adoptent ce mode de
déplacement là on sait que les
comportements ont changé que les besoins
de déplacement ont changé donc le
paiement à bord permet de je pense
conserver aussi des clients après 6 ans
de travail la Société de transport de
Laval est en avance sur les grandes
villes du Québec
les clients de la STM d'exo et d'urem
pourront aussi utiliser ce système mais
pas avant 2025 vraiment mettre à niveau
7000 points de validation les autobus
détourniqués dans le métro les les
stations au niveau de du train ça touche
le système central également donc
aujourd'hui on a un système central avec
opus qui date de vingtaine d'années faut
vraiment tout mettre ça à jour donc ça
prend un certain temps pour vraiment
s'assurer que tout fonctionne très bien
le système de paiement par carte a fait
son chemin dans d'autres provinces
depuis le mois de mai plusieurs villes
ontariennes donc Toronto utilise cette
technologie
les Calgariens peuvent déjà avoir leur
carte d'accès directement sur leur
téléphone intelligents ces innovations
font quelques jaloux à Montréal
n'importe quoi qui m'évite d'avoir à
sortir du change c'est toujours
problématique ce serait définitivement
plus rapide surtout les premiers du mois
de plus que tu peux faire
les morialets pourront dès le printemps
2024 recharger leur carte puce à partir
de leur téléphone mais ils devront
continuer de l'avoir bien en main dans
les transports en commun pendant encore
au moins deux ans ici Charles Dumoulin
Radio-Canada Montréal